probably say that the computations of a
neural network are all organized in
terms of a forward path or a forward
propagation step in which we compute the
output of the new network followed by a
backward pass or a back complication
step which we use to compute gradients
or compute derivatives the computation
graph explains why it is organized this
way in this video we'll go through an
example in order to illustrate the
computation drought let's use a simpler
example than logistic regression or a
full-blown neural network let's say that
we're trying to compute a function J
which is a function of three variables a
B and C and let's say that function is
three times a plus B times C computing
this function actually has three
distinct steps the first is you need to
compute what is B times C and let's say
we store that in a variable called u so
U is equal to B times C and then you
might compute to be musical a times u so
let's say you know this is V and then
finally your output J is V times V so
this is your final function J you trying
to compute we can take these three steps
and draw them in a computation graph as
follows
let's say I draw your three variables a
B and C here so the first thing we did
was compute u equals B times C I'm going
to put a rectangular box around that and
so the inputs of that are B and C and
then you might have V equals a plus u so
the inputs to that ah B so the inputs to
that are you which we just computed
together with a and then finally we have
J equals three times B so as I can
for example if equals five B equals V
and C equals two then du equals BC would
be six V equals a plus u be five plus
six and eleven J is three times at so J
is equal to 33 and and indeed hope you
can verify that you know this is a three
times five plus three times two and if
you expand that out
you know you actually get so these three
has the value of J so the computation
graph comes in handy when there is some
distinguished or some special output
variable such as J in this case that you
want to optimize and in the case of the
logistic regression J is of course the
cost function that we're trying to
minimize and what we've seen in this
little example is that through a
left-to-right pause you can compute the
value of J and what we'll see in the
next couple slides is that in order to
compute derivatives
Opa right to left pause like this kind
of going in the opposite direction as
the blue arrows that would be most
natural for computing the derivatives so
the recap the computation graph
organizes a computation with this blue
arrow left to right computation lets
defer to the next video how you can do
the backward red arrow right to left
computation of the derivatives let's go
on to the next video